our houses are bound by a common cause
[Music]
perhaps
but there will be blood
house of the dragon hbo's highly
anticipated game of thrones prequel
finally hit the small screen sunday
night
very good very good
but for some fans the wait lasted a
little bit longer yeah hbo max crashed
during its premiere leaving thousands of
viewers unable to watch and well very
disappointed why do you cut me so deep
the company addressed the small hiccup
telling e.t a small portion of users
trying to connect to their devices had
issues and they worked directly with
everyone impacted to get them into the
platform but hbo did confirm that the
series was also successfully viewed by
millions of subscribers and the fans
that got the privilege to watch well
they're praising the long-awaited
prequel
house targaryen stood at the height of
its strength
with 10 adult dragons under its yoke
check out this clip of a new york city
apartment building where multiple units
are enjoying the show at the same time
house of the dragon takes place 200
years before got and details the battle
of succession as house targaryen
attempts to maintain its place on the
iron throne
14 succession claims were heard
but only two were truly considered
princess rhaenys targaryen the king's
eldest descendant and her younger cousin
prince viserys targaryen
the king's eldest male descendant
spoke with the stars of the show ahead
of its premiere and they opened up about
the huge pressure of carrying on the
game of thrones legacy are you guys
ready for that level of passion to
follow you into your lives
yeah you can only trust in the moment
that what you're making is is great and
that's all you can sort of ask for i do
hope people enjoy it i know we're
walking into something that's already a
massive success so you know that's
that's a given you know that we're
walking into it's not unknown territory
in a way but i can't you can't make a
show i can't as an actor make a show and
worry about how it's going to be
received all i can do is do my best
possible job in
performing it you know look we've tried
our best to make a show that is original
and entertaining and
that's hopefully what you know we'll
have done but
we won't please everyone well so far
looks like viewers are loving it and can
catch new episodes when house of the
dragon airs sundays on hbo
[Music]
you